[Music]
welcome to star talk
your place in the universe where science
and pop culture collide
star talk begins right now
[Music]
welcome to star talk radio i'm your host
neil degrasse tyson astrophysicist and
director of new york city's hayden
planetarium for our show today i'm going
to break format a bit
normally there is a professional
stand-up comedian right to my side
serving as my co-host and we banter and
chat about the science topic of the day
reacting to interview clips that i've
slotted into the show of special guests
that i've collected over the previous
days
in this particular case i want to
present to you straight through an
exclusive one-on-one conversation that i
had with actress nichelle nichols that
name is no stranger to the geek set
among you out there but for the rest who
need a little bit of extra info
she is the legendary icon who played
lieutenant uhuru in the original star
trek television series that series was
created as many of you know by gene
roddenberry and it was groundbreaking on
many fronts
for me the most important feature of
that show
was that the deck of the starship
enterprise was international
lieutenant uhuru herself represented
again this is the future the united
states of africa
not only was she there but there was
representation from asia from europe
from the americas and even planet vulcan
of course in the guise of spock
the point is if you were a science
fiction fan of the day and you viewed
how authors and producers portrayed the
future
it was a future that did not include
people of color
a really frightening prospect if you
happen to have been a person of color
and now comes the series star trek
and you see a woman who is dignified who
has poise
who is not somebody's maid
and who is in fact an educated
communications officer on the deck of
the starship enterprise
who is fourth in command by the way of
that starship
and your vision of the future can change
overnight
this fact did not go unrealized by
michelle nichols
let's pick up on my interview with her
in my office at the hayden planetarium
here in new york city
before star trek did you have any
particular interest in science or
science fiction was that just your next
acting gig and it just blossomed into
the rest of what became an important
identity well i thought star trek was
going to be my next acting gig because i
grew up in musical theater and i never
had any dreams of being in film or
television theater people tend to be
snooty that way
the theater
i didn't know it was being snooty
you see it wasn't like that with me it
was a live audience that i loved and
that i thrived in and i and you get
immediate response to your effective
immediate response and you never do the
same performance that's how i when i
feel when i give lectures yes it's the i
feed off of that
yes that give and take isn't it i bet
even now you realize another dimension
of what you were going to say that
because of an audience reaction or
question
because you affect people in different
ways this was a very exciting time for
me when i realized my life was bigger
than my narrow i was uh interested
and became involved with all forms of
dance so the total stage performer there
i was a singer with a four octave range
voice i thought i had two voices until i
found out how to connect them
i had this high voice
you know and i had this deep voice
moaning low
oh you need that deep voice i love him
so you know i wasn't this little child
the needle on my microphone doesn't know
what to do
and i and i was this actor and i was
also a writer i used to write plays and
i'd get the kids in the neighborhood and
i cast them and i would always be the
star of the show
and they were just delighted because
they loved having fun and then our
parents would come and see it the show
the kids in the neighborhood come write
another one write another
and they got to have fun and i got to be
in as a young child in this theater the
theater on the street
and so i always knew i was going to be a
star
but it was going to be at the highest
level on broadway and you'd be the
toaster brother toast of broadway and
then
star trek interrupted my career
damn star trek i got this role as uhura
and i thought oh well that's nice you
know i didn't think of it as a leading
role i just thought of it as being a
powerful adjunct and participant of my
resume
which would get me closer to broadway
starring on broadway
who would have thought who the [ __ ] yeah
yeah i'll hack the star trek role so
that i can be better on broadway so that
i can be
sought after because i never
underestimated the power of television
so here i've got this lovely little role
and i thought it was nice and
after the first season
i thought okay i'm fantastic you know
right and you're not singing and dancing
right
no that wasn't no i wasn't i decided no
not singing in star trek yes i did three
times i missed that oh my god oh yes
[Music]
my heart is
where
[Music]
the
lovelies are growing somewhere
[Music]
beyond
[Music]
that was the first song that gene had
written for me i'm necklacing that
tonight
okay
and then i sang twice again i i sang the
oh but i really had fun it was singing
to mr spock in the rec room teasing him
about his ears and so forth and it was
fascinating to me
that that was the only time you would
see uhura relax
or be funny when she was on that command
deck
she was all business
she's from the united states of africa
she was expected to be of a level high
professionality highest of professional
not just high that's not good excuse me
yes okay well that showed let me just
say you had a presence on that deck that
no one else had and she could tease bach
because
if you ever wonder why uhura was the
only one that spock even dane to try to
teach much less teach to play the vulcan
lair
an impossible instrument even for
vulcans to play
and so i used that to relate to the
intelligence of spock
and the intelligence of my family which
in from the united states of africa most
assuredly expected the best and the
highest of their daughter
so he went through a year
and at the end of the year thank you
i was floating back there and i thought
if i talked long enough
so
after the first season
i was going well you know that this is
not a major role or it doesn't have
anything to do although i had some
really wonderful episodes
this might be the very coolest time for
me to thank gene for the opportunity
because i'm getting all of this
attention now that we're on television
and i'm on my way to broadway
and i'd already talked to a producer who
wanted to write a something around me
and so forth so an intelligent i said i
thank you for everything you've done
gene we've been friends
and i thank you so very much but i'm
going to be leaving and jeans was
sitting behind his desk and he had a
raucous sense of humor but he was not
amused
and he just looked at me and he said you
can't
don't you see what i'm achieving here
and it stunned me and because i didn't
think you know you were just another
actress on the stage yeah
and nobody had told me yet that i was
chief communications officer and fourth
in command until
two nights later and gene said we'll
take the week and and think about this
michelle
and i handed him my little letter of
resignation he stuck it in his desk
drawer and look and he said think about
it think about what i've so i've talked
to you about this is
more than just a role
i can okay gene thank you and he says if
if monday morning you want to come in
and talk to me
and you still feel the same way
i will still be very disappointed but
i'll let you go with my blessings
i said thanks gene i walked out of there
that went well
on saturday night i was had been invited
as a celebrity guest at a an naacp
fundraiser in beverly hills
and when i went in
i was being greeted and so glad you
could come so this year now was 1967
66
yes approximately that time
seven eight eight yeah there you go yeah
and just as i'm sitting
seated at the deus and getting ready to
turn to other celebrities
one of the promoters uh walked over
behind me and said miss nichols
sorry to bother you i said no problem
and he said well there's someone who
wants to meet you
and he
says he he's your greatest fan
and i'm smiling i said of course and i'm
getting up to turn and said where is he
says right over here and i'm thinking
it's a trekker you know maybe a child
maybe a young man they just someone
wants to congratulate
and so delighted i turn
and
i see this man across the room
with this brilliant smile
which you didn't often see on his face
and i remember saying to myself
whoever this little trekker is they're
gonna have to wait because this is my
leader dr martin luther king walking
towards me with a smile on his face
and i never met the man you know this is
like i'm starting to tremble
and he walks to me and he says with this
smile he says and puts his hand on says
yes miss nichols i am your greatest fan
martin luther king jr
i thought
what an incredible moment and i now i
have to wrap my head around this you are
at a fundraiser yes
you star trek actress at a fundraiser in
beverly hills yes and you run into
martin luther king well he was also a
guest no no i just i'm just saying just
just the exact and i've just told gene
roddenberry i'm leaving you're leaving
the show right okay so that's the setup
for you well this man
he's he says i am your greatest fan
and i just was
fabulous flabbergasted
you're still flabbergasted you can't say
the word remembering it
and
he begins to speak
about my role on television and the
power of
star trek and how important it is
in the meantime for the first time in my
life i had no words to say
i couldn't if they wouldn't come out
anyway i'm shaking in front of this man
and he is saying how important
star trek is to the future
that this man who's written this who has
produced this has
seen the future and we are there because
you are there and you
is the black community black community
has been imagined in the future created
by gene roddenberry it's a truth because
it's on television and
the black community was not part of
anybody else's vision of the future that
had been portrayed until now that's
correct that's correct in this next part
of the interview michelle nichols
reveals exactly what martin luther king
jr told her about the importance of star
trek to society
let's see what she had to say
he said you have one of the most
important roles this is a first
it's non-stereotypical
it's brilliant it's beauty and it's
intelligence
and you do it with warmth and grace
and i'm just standing there watching him
at listening to him i'm thinking the
only
visions i've seen of this man really
are
nightly in the news
with
marching
and black people in the south marching
and demanding their rights to sit at a
lunch counter at lunch counter
and coming out being hurt herded out and
having hoses
fire hoses
turned on them dogs
attack dogs turner men women and
children
and this man leading them and marching
and the face of all of this being
arrested every night i ever saw and i
said they're going to kill him and it
won't happen past this time but it did
and so he became this power of hope
and here i am playing this
character
that i'm going to give up
and i said to him
dr king thank you so much
i'm going to miss my co-stars and before
i could say because he said what are you
talking about what are you talking about
and
i said that i just told gene that i'm
leaving the show after the first season
because i've received and he said you
cannot
i felt like that little boy who later
said would you domo will because i felt
like saying would you talk about dr
martin luther king but my mouth just
dropped
and he said you cannot leave do you
understand
it has been
heavily ordained
this is god's gift
and onus for you
you have changed the face of television
forever
because this is not a black role
it is not a female role
anyone can fill that role it's a role
with power and dignity he said it can be
filled
by a woman of any color
a man of a man of health
it can be filled by another klingon or
some alien an alien
he said this is a unique role in a
unique point in time
that
breathes the life of what we are
marching for
equality he says beside
your chief communications officer your
fourth in command
i'm thinking nobody told me that
i mean he's paying attention to these
episodes he knows star trek is built on
the air force
on the rankings yes ranking so he knew
the rank
and he said you have no idea the esteem
that we hold for you and i'd start
shivering
and i'm just looking at him and my mouth
was quivering
and he said beside michelle you have no
idea the power
of television
this man
has shown us in the 23rd century
this man started now this man who's
created this
this
man has created a reality
and because it's in the 23rd century and
you are chief communications officer
fourth in command of a starship on going
on a five-year mission where no man or
woman is gone before
it means that what we are doing today
is just the beginning of where we're
going just how far we have to make sure
that that's enabled you cannot leave
besides and then he smiles again star
trek is the only show
that my wife coretta and i
allow our little children to stay up
late and watch
and michelle
i can't go back and tell them this
because you are their hero
so overnight
your life became bigger than yourself
exactly your role became bigger than you
i couldn't think of anything for the
rest of the weekend i was just shivering
sometimes i was furious
sometimes i was crying sometimes i just
sat numb and thought about it and i went
to gene roddenberry on wobbly legs and
and i walked into his office and he was
behind that same desk
and
jean was a six foot three
muscular hatchet-faced man with a wicked
sense of humor and a brilliant mind
and he sat there and he looked at me and
i said gene
if you still want me to stay
i'll stay and i told them the store what
had happened to me with dr martin luther
king he just looked up at me and didn't
say anything for a long time and he
opened his desk drawer and took out my
letter of resignation
and handed it to me and i looked at him
at this man and a tears rolling down his
face and he said
god bless dr martin luther king someone
knows what i'm trying someone realizes
what i'm trying to achieve
i'm getting misty-eyed just listening to
your story i mean just i can hardly ever
tell it and he handed me my letter of
resignation which had been torn up into
a million pieces from the day of the
moment i had handed into it
he wasn't going to accept it anyway
and and i said
gene do you do you know dr king and he
says i've never met him but i bless him
and because i said this is
too coincidental it was too coincidental
that i could just see him picking up the
telephone dr king
i got i got a job for you like like dr
king has nothing else to do
so the real truth here yeah is that even
though the show got cancelled it planted
seeds within the consciousness of the
nation that sprouted later greater than
anyone i think had ever imagined i think
because the show got canceled it caused
an incredible thrust of pain and furion
because so many people to this day said
i found myself
i found who i am
and people say to me women because you
were there i could never see the world
the way i was raised to see
i became a different person i had a man
in one of the star trek conventions
in london where they had the skinheads
the movement
and he was remember that obviously a
skin hit and there was a long long long
line of people and i had security behind
me who were irritating me and i've never
had anything but here was this man in
the front of the line he couldn't have
been more than maybe 1819 but he looked
more frightening with the skin head and
the whole thing and the muscles and the
tattoos and he walked over to the table
and
my security team tensed
and he says don't move miss nichols and
i said i'm not bothering the young man
walked over to me and he realized what
was going on and said whatever his name
wants and he said i'm not really here as
a fan miss nichols i just wanted you to
know
that because of you on star trek
i stopped being what i was on my day to
be
and i came here dressed as i had been
doing so that you would know
this guy is tearing and i'm looking up
at him tearing up here and now and he
said i can never be that again
he says i understand what the world and
the future is and star trek depicts it
and it's not
what i was going through with all my
pain and my life this is a former
skinhead telling you that this is a
former skinhead
and he said i've done some dastardly
things i can only hope to make up for it
and i stood
and i leaned across the table because it
wasn't really a big big table wide table
and i said come here son and i put my
arms out
and tears came down his eyes mine
and i held him
and i said
don't look for forgiveness anywhere
god just forgave you
your choice
makes you whole
and he just
he thanked me
i'm sorry
he thanked me and
and he walked away and i turned
to my
men who were securities security
and they just stood there like their
hands were just limp and one man said
well i'll be damned and i said
no
you'll be blessed he just got blessed
but that was the power of what gene
roddenberry meant and martin luther king
was right and macht martin luther king
was right and i never looked back
and he was going through some really
hard times and those only another couple
of years that we lost him
i happen to know that whoopi goldberg
credits the fact that she was on
television
in the star trek series was because of
you it was so beautiful to meet her
because she's she's such a brilliant
woman
with her
humor you you and the manner in which
she does those are human you might at
first be thrown by her and
underestimate her
she's brilliant
and when i'm actually met her in person
the next generation star trek nation was
was on and she was on the show and i'm
going oh isn't that wonderful to myself
and coincidentally we were doing one of
the now the star trek movies i think it
was the first star trek movie
and so my dressing room was a crossover
in her dressing room and her van and a
bus whatever
and mine was across the street and she
asked one of the guys on my set that she
wanted to meet me
and i'll never forget
when she met me you know when i i said
certainly absolutely and i said you want
me to come there to just you know she
said no i'm going to come to her.
and so she did and
i loved her humor so much i got it you
know and i said
you are so incredible and she just
looked at me and she said you are my
queen
and she said if it hadn't been for you i
had never been on star trek was my
favorite show and she said
when star trek came on i was nine years
old
and i saw this show and it came on and
there you were and i ran through the
house saying hey come everybody quick
quick quick come come look quick and
they came as a what's the matter what
she said there's a black lady on star
trek and she ain't no maid
there's a black lady on television and
she ain't no maid
and she said i knew from that moment
that i could become anything i wanted to
be
because you were there and i said and
you became whoopi goldberg isn't that a
blessing not only that she's working on
star trek before you even had the
occasion to learn this about her exactly
yes she'd gone into gene told me the
story gene roddenberry jean roddenberry
well he wrote the story actually was in
one of the fan magazines but he said
when her agent called
and said
well this is after she already got the
academy award for ghost so she's already
a successful yes film actress i was a
gasping fan you know
okay i'm going
she wants to meet me you know
but gene told me that her agent called
and said whoopi goldberg wants to be in
the next generation and jeanne said are
you kidding
he said she's a big star this is the
little tv this is tv plan tv
you know she's got time to do that and
so the agent was so happy to be able he
said thanks gene thanks
he goes back and tell well you can't do
it because jean said blah blah blah she
said
go back and talk to gene
roddenberry and ask him to tell me to my
face
so the agent goes to advance me and she
said he goes to tell jean jean says of
course i'll meet with her but the answer
is still no
and he said good gene just explain it to
her gene was a brilliant man
such depth in his thinking and his
vision
but he met with her
and she came in now she later told me
how nervous she was
but she came in and sat there and looked
at him and he said i have only one
question to ask you
and she said yes
and he said you're a big star
and you're a great comedian artist why
would you want to be on the little
screen on star trek
and she said
it's all michelle nichols fault
when gene told me that
i
i said what what what did i do
and then he told she told him the story
of her being nine years old and when
gene heard that story he said i'll tell
you what i'm going to do
i will create a role for you under one
condition
that you only come in and do it at your
convenience when you are not working
because i refuse to take you away from
the rest
that's a wonderful pact
and that was such an honor when i heard
it i i just when gene told me he called
me and told me and tears came i mean you
like the matriarch of an entire
generation of people coming into that
not that old yet okay but i'm
trying to find that okay
i'm i want to live to be a hundred and
between 120
and 50. okay see and then i'll take then
i'll take on that that's auspicious
when you just sit in the chair and
people come up to you yes yes yes
they'll pass you gifts
no i'll be telling them where they can
go and how far they can get if they do
the right thing
i think it's an incumbent on us as human
beings and part of this race on earth is
to
add to the goodness
that we've been given on this earth
i remember a business partner and who
passed away unfortunately before his
time
jim nihan who was before he retired and
became partners with me corporate vice
president of rockwell international who
built the space shuttle
and i met him during that point in time
he was one of the great songwriters
and this is a man of science a scientist
himself was pulled out of being a
research scientist for rockwell because
he happened to be a good organizer
they pulled him and put him in the front
offices and kept
that happens yes yes it does it does
but and when we met both of our
interests
separate from our business
brought us together
and we wrote space musicals
that encouraged young people and in the
whole world you know everybody is
something when are you going to do your
musical again when are you going to do
that he produced most of my latest
albums
but he said one day and i said
you know if we don't stop doing this
we're going to blow this earth to
kingdom come
and i said we're going to lose
everything
and he said no
it won't destroy the earth the earth's
not going to be destroyed we may destroy
ourselves but the earth will mend
earth
is earth
we've been here billions of years and
whatever yeah another billion years
left another life form of well he scared
the hell out of when he told me
and well i feel that way because all the
the green movement says save the earth
earth is going to be here long after we
are i can tell you that yes it's like
what they really mean to save us on
earth that's really what they mean
exactly and he was a chemist and my
father was a chemist
you know you meet people in your life
as i feel now i've met you neil
and whether you like it or not you've
heard my life
an important part but i i think that
fine minds
come together
fine minds of a like kind
come together and we're the salvation
of america of
any other
country
of this whole planet the founding
fathers those fight minds coming
together yes yes fine the right time at
the right place right time in the right
place and what we decide and move the
foundations that we're doing the work
that you're doing
the ambition
the foolish ambition of a future that we
have
dismisses all the negativities
that is a hopeful vision that is a
hopeful vision i think it's a positive
and i think it's a real vision
it's a vision that will save the world
because there are enough people out
there who think like we think
so often a mission dies with its creator
yes or it gets forgotten
it fades
none of the above as it
right now where are you going to be
oh i think when kingdom comes on the
moon
didn't they put him on the they put his
ass beyond them
his
but if i remember correctly they
attached some of his ashes to uh lunar
yes the lunar craft that i i hope to
join him you can join him on the moon
looking down on earth or wherever out
there
because out there is forever yep yep and
if there's and if not forever it's for
billions of years billions and billions
and billions
so michelle i have to tell the radio
audience that you've donned this morning
a red jacket
now this is taboo for star trek people
because we all know what happened to the
people who we've read in a star trek
episode
i think maybe that's why uhura never got
to get off the bridge i guess she never
did did she she was too smart
[Laughter]
[Applause]
it's okay you guys go take the guy in
the red
so therefore you could wear red and be
safe
you bet
somebody's got to take care of the ship
and who better than chief communications
officer fourth in command
lieutenant of hoorah you've got it all
away
i hear often people talk of science
fiction as a unique genre because you
can tell
social cultural
stories that might be taboo for normal
fiction or just kind of out of reach if
when i was a kid
i wasn't a science fiction
fan as such
but i knew
that it existed and i didn't think of if
i read something that was science
fiction or fictional i
regarded it in this context as a piece
of literature
i didn't know there were people that
read science fiction
devotedly
or that there were other people who
thought they were all geeks or nuts
if i liked it it was either good fiction
and if i didn't like it it happened to
be science exactly that happened to me
scientific and i liked it in in that
context it was good i loved it
and there came a point in time
as a young girl
i see people
on the elevated line or on a bus
reading a book
and engrossed in it
and it was wrapped in brown paper bag
because
if it was obvious that they were
reading i s i came to learn that it was
obvious they were reading science
fiction they were treated in a certain
kind of weird way like you're really a
geek you know like
and for the rest of my life whenever i
saw a brown paper and i said
they're reading something it must be
really really good that would always be
science fiction in secret yes as a
singer like as though nobody knew but
nobody would then bother them you know
but i thought and again i i said that i
had
read of what was i came to understand as
science fiction
but i read everything i was a voracious
reader and it didn't matter to me
whether it was shakespeare or a love
novel if it had something really to say
or science fiction if it impacted
life as we know it and made you think
lady chatterley's lover
you know makes you stop and think about
the power of controlling people
not who they are but what they're
supposed to be in society and how they
respond and act to that you can take
that and set it in any setting and you
go all the way from early science
fiction to harry potter and it's
interesting and it touches on how we
think about
life in our place in it now there are
people that get really really really
really
interested but they become fandom you
know
and because there's something there that
speaks to them
and so i always thought of it that way
not as a science fiction reader or a
non-science fiction reader
but i think that science fiction and
especially
gene roddenberry's star trek
and that really loosened the minds of a
lot of people and you see a lot of
science fictional television now some of
it's good some of it's not so good but
it's imaginative
it takes you into
another world and it's still
about a sense of morality of who we are
who we choose to be and who we choose
not to be
i would say star trek episodes at their
best hit every one of those pistons
absolutely when they were firing all
together i think that's what touched
amazingly so many people and for the
first time
you saw science fiction or anything else
with males and females as equals of all
colors
and that was amazing in positions of
power
coming from every attitude from from a
high level
of understanding or compassion to the
lowest
didn't matter who you were what color
you were or what planet you came from so
there were complete characters fleshed
out completely
mind body emotion exactly
and with each
having a lesson at the end
that you could take home with you you
could take home with you but you could
breathe it in
or not
or you can laugh and you could have fun
or you could go that was so cool
or that was so deep
or that was so me
that was me doing that was me in that
character what you're saying is that if
it's a good show at the end
something's going to come out of it and
you're going to have to react to that in
some way or another a life's lesson
how you accept it and if you want to you
will be a better person for it and too
many shows nothing comes out of it yeah
yeah yeah hour's gone and you don't even
remember why what you did that hour
exactly so what
you know that's an hour i'm never
getting back for the rest of my life you
hit the mail
everyone knows but we got to remind
everybody that you had the first
interracial kiss on television i was
part of the first interview i'm sorry
yeah it took two i'm sorry let me
clarify that
i didn't kiss bill shatner
bill shatner kissed me kissed you
but actually uhur didn't and and captain
kirk were forced
to embrace oh i forgot about that it was
a force power kinetic
only give you a non-interracial kiss
[Laughter]
michelle thanks for being on star talk
radio thank you so much
that about wraps up our show for the
week thanks for listening
what you heard was my exclusive
interview with actress nichelle nichols
lieutenant uhura of star trek fame
you may be delighted to learn that we
have an entire other hour of this
interview
soon to arrive in our star talk
broadcast
this is neil degrasse tyson signing off
for star talk and as always keep looking
up
[Music]
you